I'm not joined by the environment
secretary at Terese coffee very good
morning to you Therese coffee lots to
talk about this morning but first of all
I wonder what your reaction is to Elon
Musk completing his takeover of Twitter
is that something to be welcomed do you
think look certainly a big move by Elon
Musk uh much thrilled and started to
negotiate early in the year but I think
it's a significance he's decided to
invest in this social media site
although mittly is a politician at times
it feels like an anti-social media site
but it's an important way of how people
communicate around the world and we'll
see what the next steps are well yes he
has called himself a free speed
absolutist he's been critical of
Twitter's moderation policies some
people are concerned that relaxing
moderation policies could mean that a
hate speech would be allowed to
proliferate is that something that
worries you well I think that would be
concerning
um and it's important that people who
have these platforms use them
responsibly rather than to promulgate
hate but it's also important to have
safety which is another reason why we're
bringing back or carrying on with the
Online safety bill in Parliament next
week Donald Trump U.S president former
of course
um still banned from the platform at the
moment Elon Musk in the past has
described that as foolish would you like
to see Donald Trump back on Twitter uh I
have no view on Donald Trump being on
Twitter at all um candidly that's going
to be a matter for Twitter okay well
let's move on to other issues you're now
Secretary of State for the environment
as of this week of course why is Rishi
Sue like not attending cop 27.
well I've been to three cops in the past
and uh the UK hands over the presidency
Alex Sharma will do that on the very
first day of uh the uh of cop but I
think it's uh normal uh leave the case
that every five years the big political
cops happen and that's when you see as
we saw in Glasgow last year uh all the
different heads of state and prime
ministers coming from around the world
uh in between they tend to be more
detailed at the discussions but other
senior ministers including myself will
be going uh to Egypt to charmele Sheikh
for different aspects where we come
together to talk about specific issues
whether that's water nature energy but
the big push was happened last year in
Glasgow well yes but cop 27 is is very
important and especially at a time like
this especially when the UN just
yesterday said that the climate crisis
has reached a really Bleak moment and
the progress has been woefully
inadequate is it really the time to just
not show up as prime minister was to say
it's I'm not aware if say President
Biden or macron or any of those other
people will be there it is quite
standard practice that every five years
is the big uh the biggest changes
they're putting more emphasis on the on
these annual meetings well there's
always the annual meetings have always
been important I mean this year in
particular we're seeing also the
convention on nature it's called by the
convention of biodiversity as well as
one on legal trade of uh endangered
species so there's a number of different
things coming together so it's gonna
it's an important year for the
environment but we have held the
presidency for the last year and it's
important that we hand that over now to
Egypt but we will continue to do as we
are doing working towards different ways
of how we meet our carbon budget
domestically but also the support that
we give around the world uh to uh
different countries and how we take that
forward and we certainly showed
leadership last year when we really set
ourselves challenging targets and we
will continue I'd say to work with
Partners around the world to help them
deliver their commitments to but what
message does it send out to those
Partners around the world and given that
you're saying that the environment is
still a priority why then in 48 hours as
prime minister has Rishi sunak not only
pulled out of cop27 but he's taken alak
Sharma out of the cabinet and also at
the climate Minister Graham Stewart is
also out of the cabinet as well is this
a failure of leadership on the climate
issue is this no longer a priority not
at all I think it is very much a
priority and the Prime Minister said
that in Downing Street
um look I returned to defra I have I had
three years as a minister there before
as the environment and we work in in
Partnership right across government in
order to deliver our carbon budgets but
as I say the UK is actually handing over
the presidency on the very first day
it's important that we allow the normal
cop functions to carry on but I want to
reiterate several senior government
ministers will be attending and his
normal practice that every five years is
when the big uh if you like the prime
minister's in EDSA State tend to attend
um we understand or reports suggested
that Liz trust when she was prime
minister advised King Charles not to
attend cop 27 will he now be advised
that he can go under Richie sunac
um I don't I'm not aware that uh Liz
ever advised uh the uh the king of that
um but I'm conscious that um King
Charles has always taken a very deep
interest in the environment and climate
change and of course it would be up to
him to decide how he chooses uh where to
put his priorities in his uh in his
reign as king would you like to see him
there I think as I've just explained
earlier normally the big cops tend to be
every five years the United Kingdom
hosted that last year where we had
attendance from many members of the
world family but in between it tends to
be more of a I'm not going to say
low-key but not quite the same level of
uh of a heads of state and prime
minister's attending would you like to
see King Charles go to cop27 I think
it's up to him I know that he he has
takes an interest in this particular
issue but it's up to him there are
reports this morning that Rishi sunak is
drawing up plans to expand the windfall
tax further on energy companies that
Levy stands at 25 at the moment will he
increase it well I'm sure that he's
working with his Chancellor Jeremy Hunt
to explore all the different elements in
the run-up to the medium-term fiscal
plan which has been put back by a couple
of weeks I think it's important that the
prime minister of course he was the
chancellor beforehand and can work
together with his Chancellor to decide
how best to make sure that we have that
longer term budget that will put us back
on the path to a percentage falling as
our debt falling as a percentage of GDP
but as environment secretary would you
like to see that happen I think I'm not
going to get into discussion about tax
because that really is a matter for the
chance in the prime minister so you've
got no view then on whether or not he
should expand the remit to include
Renewables as well well
um can I put it this way government is
don't have personal views this is about
governments going through that the new
prime minister will be working with the
chancellor to decide where to best
recognize the financial situation and
how we address that
can I move on to Northern Ireland now
because the deadline passed at midnight
tonight for politicians to come together
and restore power sharing in Northern
Ireland that that deadline has been and
gone the government says that elections
will follow what do you think elections
though will solve in Northern Ireland
well I think it's regrettable the
parties were not able to come together
to form that executive but the law was
clear we passed the legislation that
this would happen
and clearly not that wasn't sufficient
agreement to be able to avoid the
elections that wasn't in the hands of
the government that was in the hands of
the parties representing the different
communities in Northern Ireland I hope
that uh in the next elections will
provide us excuse me will be an
opportunity for people to reconsider
their approach recognizing the new
decade new approach agreement that was
signed only a couple of years ago and we
need to make sure that that we do what
we can to to work together to try and
make that come to fruition but
realistically nothing's going to change
is it the dup are adamant they will
stick to their policy of refusing to
return to power sharing in less than
Northern Ireland protocol is removed and
elections are just going to be expensive
and they could make matters worse rather
than better with with views and
trenching well the Prime Minister spoke
to the T-shirt yesterday and clearly
this is a situation of concern and
regret but I think both uh the um this
Administration this government but also
the Irish government will be continuing
to try and work to try and bring
together that government the formation
of the executive after the elections I
met the Deputy Prime Minister
last week and there is clear emphasis
that both our government and the Irish
government want the executive form and
we will keep up our efforts to do so
well is there any chance that you could
bring forward legislation that means
that the the elections don't have to to
go ahead well they definitely happen do
you think um they will they will
definitely happen
okay any movement on the talks with the
EU over the protocol
well I know that the Prime Minister has
always wanted to have a a negotiated
outcome uh clearly the Prime Minister
was part of the government under Boris
Johnson when we brought forward the
northern Line Post call Bill but it's
important those talks continue as well I
want to move on to the issue of um the
Home Secretary bravaman and her return
to her position after after six days of
having left it it still concerns around
her breaking of the ministerial code
after sharing sensitive information Lord
blanclet has now said that Security
Services could be reluctant to share
sensitive information with the Home
Secretary does that worry you
I don't think that's the case some the
Home Secretary recognized um that she
had breached the ministerial code last
week and clearly the Prime Minister has
now had a chance to go through this and
satisfied himself uh such that he
reappointed uh suela to be the Home
Secretary
um you know the very serious matters
happening in our country uh of course
our intelligence services and our police
will continue to work with the Home
Secretary uh giving her the full
information that she needs in order to
be able to make her decisions protecting
safety but of course also her main
priority right now is about the illegal
migrations that are happening the the
small boats Crossing and I know she'll
put her full efforts into that and on
the subject of immigration Sola Bravo
man has said that she wants to get net
migration to tens of thousands is that
now an official government Target well
um as far as I'm aware the Prime
Minister will be discussing those
matters but the key priority my
understanding is about tackling the
small boats if I think about uh We've
stopped nearly thirty thousand Crossings
and just in the Sierra is my
understanding that's what I've been told
and I recognize there are a lot of
people here here illegally that's why we
strengthened early in the year the law
about how we want to handle those cases
uh but uh I think that partnership with
France is critical uh and indeed the
Prime Minister has been raised that I
think in his discussions with the French
President so no Target on immigration
um I'm not aware there's any change to
policy uh but Focus I think is about
illegal migration
just want to ask you a quick question
about Liz truss you uh you've always
described as a close political Ally but
you're a really good friend of hers
aren't you yes give us an idea of how
tough this week's been for her how's she
doing have you spoken to her
um I have of course been in touch uh
with Liz and she's a good friend she's
with her family and I think she's
deserving uh enjoying a well-deserved
break and you were very close to her
politically and personally were you
surprised then that you were given such
a prominent job in Richardson that's
cabinet well um I worked with the Prime
Minister previously when I was a working
pensions and he was
um in uh being a Chancellor I think I'm
known within government as being a
person who delivers and gets on with the
job and I was delighted when he asked me
to stay in the cabinet and to take on
the role of deaf secretary I've spent
three years in the department before so
I can hit the ground running and there
are many important issues to deal with
there as we continue to want to try and
make sure that we leave the the world
and indeed our country in a better State
and for future Generations than we
inherited